voilà [ __ ] trois ans comme on dirait
au guignol alors michel platini bonsoir
est ce que ce grand stade en trop sera
prêt à temps et est ce que vous avez
trouvé tous vos sponsors le grand stade
sera bien sûr fini à temps comme la
rénovation des autres notes stade qui
sera aussi termine à temps pour la coupe
du monde où je répétais une chaussée qui
aura 37 milliards de regards qui qui est
supporteront sur la france il y aura dix
mille journalistes qu'ils jugeront la
france et les français donc on a intérêt
à être temps pour 7 pour ce grand
événement qui est le plus grand de
l'histoire de la france en ce qui
concerne ce qui concerne le nombre de
personnes qui vont regarder l'événement
donc le stade sera prêt il ya aucun
problème les stades seront prêts et
l'organisation sera paraître sinon on ne
serait pas là ce soir et au niveau du
marketing on a eu la chance aujourd'hui
de trouver un partenaire extraordinaire
la présence en signant un contrat avec
france télécom qui va nous permettre de
régler tous les problèmes de
télécommunication qu'on aura pour juste
en 1998 c'est encore plus de travail que
d'habitude pour vos prédécesseurs parce
que cette fois il ya trente deux équipes
en lice est à 32 équipes ça fait
soixante quatre matches il ya deux
millions sept cent mille personnes qui
vont pouvoir voir les mages donc 2
millions 700 mille îles à vendre dans le
monde entier y aura de gros problèmes de
logistique enfin il y aura pas mal de
davantage mais je trouve que c'est un
beau très passionnant et c'est vrai
qu'on a plus de boulot cno précédesseur
un pigment est ce que tu peux nous dire
d'un mot ya apparemment des changements
de réglementations qui vont intervenir
juste avant ou à l'occasion de cette
coupe du monde notamment ceux cette
fameuse mort subite
il faut plus appeler la mort subite il
faut l'appeler le but de la victoire ou
le golden ball en anglais c'est vrai
qu'il y aura pendant la période des
prolongations à la fin du match comme je
sais que vous vous intéressez au foot
bal je sais très bien donc pour les
fabrications la première équipe qui
marquera sera qualifié et si on peut ne
plus aller aux tirs au but ce sera une
bonne chose
et à la fin des à la fin des
prolongations ci a toujours 0 0 1 ou 1
et bonnie wright aux tirs au but il peut
aussi une procédure de d'exclusions
temporaires n'ont pas pour l'instant pas
pour maintenant
alors pour une fois les bleus seront
qualifiés puisque nous sommes
la puissance invitante alors d'un mot
quelques espoirs vous former pour cette
qui vous me direz que c'est dans trois
ans et qu'on sait pas bien qui sera sur
le terrain à ce moment là mais d'une
part ces mesures je ne suis pas le
sélectionneur donc c'est difficile de
savoir les jeunes pousses qui sont
actuellement en ligne aux portes de
l'équipe de france
mais le football français mais bon vous
savez la dernière fois on a loupé la
qualification pour pas grand chose
d'important israël pour vraiment des
quelques bêtises on les isole les les
bulgares et les cieux de la qui sont
qualifiés à notre place et des moins
bons que nous ils entrent en demi-finale
ça je vois pas grand chose et je pense
qu'on a toutes les chances de
d'éventuellement de gagner la coupe du
monde 1998
justement est ce qu'il ya un heureux
précédent de voir l'équipe de handball
qui est donc la première équipe
française dans un sport collectif à
obtenir un titre mondial pour vous c'est
un challenge comme on dit oui bah je
vais vous dire un petit show j'ai envoyé
un télégramme il ya quelques semaines à
l'équipe de france de rugby jury après
les handballeurs et avant les
footballeur en 98 02 tour merci beaucoup
michel platini et bon courage et rendez
vous dans trois ans ou peut-être même un
petit peu avant a tout de même à vendre